hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Fran bow now I got
all the technical problems worked out so
everything should be roughly back to
where they were and hopefully my
computer won't crash again
so what we did in the last episode or I
can't remember exactly where it cut off
but there was a little bit of a
revelation that I had oh you're all
skinny yeah I'm pretty sure that I did
this in the last episode but just in
case I didn't I'm starting here because
I can't be bothered differently to go
back and look but I don't know if I
mentioned in the last one but it was
really interesting that in the in the
world where I take the pill when I put
the key on the rack the key actually
literally goes there and she can't see
me so in the beginning phase did the
doctor just not know I was there or is
this just because her back was turned on
me like that's the big question here I
can't remember on Grace's phone number
I'll to surprise her when I get home
Oh a love letter dear Pete Oh gross
grown-up stuff okay I don't have any
more keys okay so the code is here I
definitely didn't do this for you guys
last time or I don't think I did so
December 17th is 12 plus 17 which is 30
none 29 and July 25th is 7 plus 25 which
is 32 so 29 and 32 2 9 3 2 bang got it
I'm the best I'm the very best those are
my lines but I'm trying to be a bit more
calm in the narration here also I did
discover there are two different things
that I did that I did not do in my last
playthrough because I had to play
through from the beginning again because
I'm on my old Ricou my old computer that
hasn't had as many problems crashing so
the first of which that old lady in the
first conversation she never put me back
in the room because I managed to
convince her that the doctor told me
that I needed to go eat we're in the
last one she put me back in the room and
I thought I told her the same thing
and in this one the security guard I
actually got him to eat the drug laced
donut or cinnamon bunny because I want a
different dialogue path so what that
tells me is that there's different ways
to approach certain situations depending
on how you talk to people and their
responses will be dicta
by what you say to them so I don't know
if this is gonna be the same because it
crashed later and I had to cut it
forward because I was only able to there
it is
you little [ __ ] I will make you pay for
what you did you woke up quick I didn't
spill oh oh yeah that's the same hello
hi hey how's it going you clever little
girl do you think you can just leave
Oh God Oh God what it can't be no okay
what happened oh hey all right did you
save me that's good I think okay then
bye all righty then
I need to get to the maze in my deep
manly voice that Fran bow has come back
here little pretty kitty oh man that's
cool okay so I need to get to the maze I
imagine the mazes start of chapter two
man I was really cool it crashed before
right when the the monster whoa oh so
he's not dead wait a mine just slipping
into the shadow world I don't know what
else to call it besides the shadow world
am i just slipping in and out oh wait is
this oh I am controlling this and why do
I have a fast-forward symbol I don't
think I should be able to skip over this
oh this is adorable oh look at that
I imagine it's probably very sinister
but I guess if you were sick of the maze
and you didn't want to go through the
whole game but I mean why would I do
that it's it's pretty I think I mean
it's not nearly as disturbing and bloody
as a lot of the other things in this
game I'm sure I I'm sure that would
change very soon okay so I I'm I think
I'm looking for my cab while I'm in here
hello is this important oh hi what is
that
this is so weird because a lot of
elements of this game juxtapose the
childish antics that Fran Bo does get
into sometimes and like the fact that
they are all children and they're all
interacting with each other in childish
ways like drawing a picture for the King
to gives Kane but that's just opposed
against like the horrible bloody gory
environment that it's in in the shadow
world and that is really weird alrighty
then
I guess I'm winning I don't know exactly
what I'm supposed to be doing okay I
mean it's really interesting and really
charming but also really disturbing at
the same time and it's hard for
something to pull off something that's
charming
and disturbing like it's very rare that
I that actually happens in games or in
movies for that matter I mean there's
there's an element of using like
children as horror pieces in a movie
like a remember from The Shining the
twins in the hallway like the creepy
creepy twins like sometimes the fact
that there are children in a seemingly
insane and horrible environment can lead
to a lot of different elements of fear
that aren't originally there because
aren't we all children inside it's
probably something profound that I could
say about all that but I don't have the
mental capacity to formulate my thoughts
properly I'll just keep me entering
through words I can see why there's a
fast-forward thing now because this
seems to be whew
this seems to be a little bit tedious
here and also really weird like why was
this just insert after everything seemed
to be in a giant panic there was a giant
monster that was after me and then
apparently the cat on the unicycle was
able to scare it away I don't know if
that's symbolic of anything but that's
all I got for now oh hello oh good I
entered a sewer pipe I got an
achievement for I found my way out at
the end of the maze you will find the
evil critters of the night
they will hunt you they will laugh
but there will always be a good side a
cat full of nuts and bolts
we'll always your guide
Oh Oh No how did that fall out of my on
Grace's purse or no that was my mom's
purse well I guess I'm just leaving that
behind then I don't know why yes I can't
go back for that chapter two part one
curiosity symptoms yellow for that the
other chapter being my sober day I sure
did pop a lot of pills but they did
discover a lot of things too
Oh oh my goodness that was close where
am I oh there I am
this is like a literal literal going
down the rabbit hole
I hope the guards don't find the sewer I
don't think the guards get paid enough
to go down into the sewer after you I
think they just leave you for lost see
oh this instrument is pretty it reminds
me of a snake that sounds like an
elephant trumpet I used to play that I
remembered something funny okay a very
old uncle tried to blow on one of these
haha he farted all his Casaus out
because it was so hard to blow okay that
is pretty funny good job it can be good
to have a cozy place to stay I know a
story about a girl with red shoes and
she had a dog and she got sent to a
horrible world Wow how a piano sounds
old what about the barrel mr. midnight
are you in there probably not let's see
what the shadow world has to
oh that's different this is completely
different instead of being bloody and
gory it's ghostly and actually not all
that bad oh I can make something out of
this okay a door so I devote okay bye
then
thank you so I picked up a door I didn't
even know like how am I supposed to be
able to tell exactly what is good and
what is bad who dares to leave an
innocent teddy without shelter oh hi
well that's probably bad should I get
this key where's this a trap
okay curiosity is damned damn you
curiosity oh I like to be curious
otherwise how will you learn things see
anyway why won't you allow me to take
the key what are you what is the right
question but why should be more
embroidery it I don't have time to chat
sir I want the key that's all oh but the
key is in ours it's not for yours for
sure it's always good to have an extra
key especially when you're up to
something we couldn't care less the
affection towards you is simply none you
are very honest I like that I'm a person
Fran pleased to meet you interesting
tell us more I have a cat well I had one
he's missing now I have to find him
really yes really
now please give me the key look person
friend we came from the south flying as
always and one of us got curious about
this key and all of us got stuck here
and because of our long hair we can't
get it loose so you are also curious can
I help you
we usually get stuck on trees but we
have something to fix that
a beautiful comb to comb our hair every
time we get stuck
all right do that then there is a
problem
a filthy thief took the comb now we are
stuck forever if you find the thief and
the comb you will have the key deal yes
but what does he look like
it's a rat a filthy narcissist rat he
took the comb to be beautiful we
couldn't do much so he ran away with it
please find it and free us from
curiosity I'll find him I hope he hasn't
gone too deep in the forest
I'll find him we will be here waiting
sadly just floating heads that's all
okay doesn't seem like there's a lot
different whoa okay I went
mid-transition and I didn't go all the
way into the other world oh we do bug
out the game wow there's a really big
insect oh wow you're really big ant
who's there oh excuse me sir are you
real ah you oh it has the same thing
always always what do you mean by always
of course I'm real where did you come
from
oh I escaped the mental hospital but
please don't tell anybody
I won't tell don't worry but what are
you doing here my cat is out here
somewhere and I have to find him a cat
who's hey yes sir a black cat with very
big yellow eyes mr. midnight oh I see
I'm sorry girl oh so you haven't seen it
it happens to be that the cat is eaten
chewed and swallowed Oh eaten what do
you mean the black cat came towards me
in a hurry
I catch it I give it to my B to pick my
B to pig is hungry my poor Beatle Pig
hasn't had any food in days the
blueberry time passed by and we ate them
all stop it
can't you see mister midnight is the
only one I have please tell me that
you're joking also said o little girl
don't cry I can sing for you if you like
well I do now you don't know how it
feels to be alone I do know yes I'm the
last one alive let me help you yes how
could you possibly help me the digestion
is not so fast you know
maybe he's still alive inside the beetle
Pig should I do something like make the
beetle Pig vomit kill the beetle Pig
he'll also the only friend I have left
but I need the meat Oh God that's sad
I'm curious to know if my kitty is still
in there do it you can kill my beetle
Pig and I antoniou the greatest shall
eat the meat well this seems like a fair
deal I suppose hmm I'm glad you didn't
cut the middleman and just eat my cat oh
you Pig did you eat my cat maybe I can
find out oh absolutely no one's here
except a shadow drifting in the
background that's not helpful at all
well how am I gonna kill a beetle pig I
only got a wooden door and a crayon I
could imagine myself up something all
right
hello mr. owl oh there's an axe over
there what kind of bird are you uh an
owl I literally just said that thank you
so should I take these mics see whoa the
terrible axe
I will be the warrior savior of things
maybe I can combine it with a door nope
I don't want to destroy the door but I
do want to destroy a beetle Pig just on
a whim
hi make an entry I'm guessing that I
would use that with the axe and that
would work out
you look like an owl is that it your
feathers are beautiful and glowing so
I'm under the impression that maybe this
is a choice he maybe I don't have to
kill the beetle big because I would
imagine that it's not entirely true hmm
I mean there could be like I mean he
said he needed the meat so what else
would I do
I guess I mean I guess I guess I have to
live with this decision
oh no wait a fig I feel so bad I know
it's probably not actually my cat wake
up the pig won't stay still
oh he's sleeping Oh seems it shouting oh
hello fetal pig oh you Pig did you eat
my cat I don't know here yeah oh he
won't stay still
that's really sad oh he's probably just
gonna go back and forth between these
two if he goes back to the other place
after this one then definitely I'm not
supposed to be accident oh no hang on
wait a minute oh hello hello beetle Vega
how are you doing now there's no way
plus I'm just a little girl how am I
supposed to be able to do that what I
probably definitely could do is using
axe on this little thinner idea
and this would lead me somewhere I need
to go bing-bong okay
I sell the axe - so what a bluff there's
no hole in here Oh
maybe means make an entry by literally
putting New York I should make it into a
complete door before trying this I don't
hit you that oops sorry
do I draw on it draw a handle nothing of
course what was I thinking I don't know
I'm thinking random thoughts I'm a
little girl lost in and at the real
world of nightmares what else could I
possibly do maybe what happens if I use
the axe on this tree what would that do
probably that's another way that I could
go but I only use that as the last
reward as a resort so there's got to be
something else here that I can I mean it
doesn't exactly was that horse there I
don't remember that horse being there
flex playing spot the difference the
king would like this one not going back
though he must escape himself so maybe
there's something else I could use this
on no um oh hey how's it going there
sorry I didn't mean to use the axe on
that even though you look like a
cat-like shadow monster use the axe on
the teddy bear I won't even try that
then why did you go up to it maybe the
axe on the bed it looks a little late as
it is trying out things is good but in
this case it won't do any good okay so
that's a little hopeless so my only my
only idea left is that I could
where else would I go that I would find
a rat the only rat that I saw was in the
crawling in the vents in the last
episode but I don't think I can go back
at all I can't even go back into the
thing any difference let me just see if
there's one more difference you know it
doesn't look like it okay so the only
other thing I can think of is that I
could use this on this sometimes things
just won't work okay so that's
definitely not it then I have to find a
way to make this a complete door before
I go through and how do I do that
Oh feather oh okay I'll keep it I didn't
know the Owls missing feather tickle
tickle can it combined with the door no
maybe I can tickle the pig maybe I can
tickle fart him out of there
piggy piggy you want a piggy piggy piggy
use a feather on the beat of it even if
it works I wouldn't know for what
purpose maybe I'd use it on tickle
tickle
huh the sword is great right oh man you
just had a flashback see Sir wake up now
I think the beetle Pig doesn't like the
idea of being killed
ah yeah but that is completely normal
isn't it yes but what should i do then
you have to give him the special marries
the blueberries hmm but there are no
berries in the woods I shouldn't say
this to you but I have the right
connection [ __ ] inside my house
they have blueberries my house is in
that direction
be careful oh thank you sir thank you
for opening up this mysterious road to
travel upon I wonder how this can go
wrong oh hey oh oh what hello from
bit-bit look fram I'm in danger find me
alive find me dead pip finally some day
at a golden cage roses okay that's weird
why is that what's with the mechanical
cat I mean it's obvious that I'm
desperate for a little cat but I'm
desperate to find my cat
that's interesting wow this a really
began hill okay all right then
hello this must be the aunt's house
seems to be open but very stuck power of
destruction we'll take it down well I'm
a little girl with nothing but the power
of destruction so I'll give it a go oh I
broke the door well too bad for me but
at least I got the doorknob so if I use
this with this this is perfect with the
handle won't stay on okay so I'm gonna
figure out another thing to get that on
there like this glue perfect okay I
shouldn't take other stuff but I want
superglue for the attachment
okay so combine that with that combine
that with that and we got a fully
functional door that's good for me
because now I can go forward two times
sir someone forgot to clean the brush
this is really where an ant lives is odd
I thought ants never cooked their meals
maybe it's not an ant maybe it's not an
ant at all
what is this Underpants ant Underpants
they smell good
grandpa soap Oh gross there's water in
the sink maybe sir aunt likes to drown
tiny monsters in there that's a little
bit of a dark thought Fran it's really
weird
or maybe he's just too clean at like
she's surprised at the dark thoughts
that she says that's what I noticed when
she was talking like she has moments
where it's like really dark like the
hands on the handprints on the bed and
the dolly bloody hand presume stealing
your soul horrible blanket a lot of
creatures like bugs and such eat your
brain
hello oh hi oh is it time to get the
berries excuse me you are all really
really weird
can I have your berries poink oh oh no
why am i doing that for the baby take
that baby okay so that one's sharpening
a doodad sir you look so angry wow
you're very rare okay
Lady pinecone woody cover Howie
okay blueberries al that hurts oh
there's got to be a way that I can get
around this you distract them
okay maybe drop a baby oh and they're on
that okay so there's got to be a way to
sneaky around this maybe five maybe if I
take a pill I'll get a better idea
oh that's not what I was expecting
holy crap whoa I'm not taking that bag
not with all these ants on it well I
don't know exactly how to get rid of the
ants oh my goodness a pest exterminator
and he's dead tiny creatures please
don't eat me oh this does not look
friendly uh sir you have tons of ants on
you don't know have you noticed
aha there we go okay so I can get up
here and then I can get the meat okay
you wouldn't mind if I take a little
meat for those who hunger and maybe
those who hunger is the ones inside the
house I mean this is a lot of meat for a
little family but I do what I can
oh I know oh I know what this is for oh
I know what this meat is for this meat
is not for me this meat is for the ants
because the hands
meet and then they'll get away from the
bag yeah ah there we go so now I can get
the bag I can get what I need XANA the
bag shows an anti bug sign the bags open
so I got River though this is
exterminator John Flom it 7 1 4 2 1 7 2
8 okay then so I've got a phone number
if I find a phone I could probably bring
that up good enough here so now I can go
back to here and probably use the trap
here so that he won't be able to stab me
away from his doodads ah there we go
this might hurt him though oh oh he's
not that bad okay I got the berries oh
oh now you're getting me how about a
baby
Onoda baby ha ha ha ha I got them they
smell delicious ha ha you're all gonna
starve
oh no they locked the door maybe they
should have done that in the beginning I
was a horrible guest to have over ok so
what is that it the queen of meat oh
he's an ant
oh he would find that attractive oh ok
well are her ID then I found ant porn oh
hi
you're supposed to be in my nightmares
why are you in the reality ah a constant
okay I see what's going O goodbye then
ok and then so that is interesting ok so
we finally have something that's
actually a constant its world and now I
have the berries which can make the bug
stay still so I can murder it be de
Parys well you Pig did you eat my kid
how about a little bit of this oh gosh
oh gosh oh oh that's not a cat at all
what you're not my cat
Elias you saved me from misery
where is mr. midnight I assume that you
are feeling disappointed who are you
looking for my cat my lovely cat mr.
midnight Oh miss lady I'm not very fond
of cats you know a black one with a very
big yellow eyes was trying to catch me
really my cat is also black wait maybe
that cat is my cat I'm a really smart
ten-year-old oh my lady if he is then
he's the one in trouble now tell me
where you saw him the last time please I
can show you follow me please
it's not far from here okay are you
gonna give me anything sorry about your
Pig sir thank you now we eat
I can't just so you know inside the
beetle Pig there was not a cat but a rat
her hat oh I'm sorry you see my eyes are
very old and I'm afraid you killed my
best friend for nothing I also have
heart problems and have very bad back
but I do enjoy the queen of meat every
once in a while I also have a Binaca
lepsy there's not much okay goodbye sir
I think anyway I think you fall asleep
oh here we are
somebody took a Miss they just
disappeared oh my goodness could you be
more specific I wish I could it looked
like the earth swallowed them if there's
anything else I can do for you just let
me know I'll be around
excuse me did you steal a hair comb oh
the hair comb the shiny beautiful hair
comb can I have it please
all right then but can you please comb
my hair first yes I can comb you here oh
that's adorable he looks so happy I mean
it's weird but happy thank you my lady
you are very kind okay I got a hair comb
now I can get a key because I imagine
them when I set up this door I don't
think I can get the thanks bags very
sorry Beatle pig I wish it didn't kill
you
but too late for that I guess okay no
soul of the demon pig or the Beatle pig
waiting for me in the afterlife okay so
now I have a comb I can use a comb to
untangle them here oh I can use the calm
to untangle the hair here's your
beautiful comb misters that's less cute
that's less adorable that's really
creepy actually oh wow oh you Fran
person you finally did it
hope the key opens the door you wish to
open now if I self at last goodbye I
don't know if that was the voice I
originally used for I always forget my
voices Oh beautiful
good shiny misters have a nice trip okay
then I'll take the Keith alright so I
got the key that I can use on the door
once I set it up at least that's what I
imagined that it's supposed to happen
it's probably what's supposed to happen
Oh God
rat who did this to you was it my kitty
oh gosh oh okay you're fine
it's weird nod at that never mind okay
so I gotta set up indoor use on there
it's really odd my own door is locked so
if I use this on bad hey there we go I
got a key to a door that I made that the
key was available before that's really
weird some backwards logic going on here
but I bet that's the end of chapter 2
part 1 what a curious little door I
wonder where it will lead me mr.
midnight are you here oh oh that's not
good
oh all right then I'll fall asleep then
it was so scary I fell asleep when you
poked me in the eye with your weird hand
tongue chapter 2 part 2 double
personnality oh so this is where the
other half of me comes out great oh oh
my goodness where am I I don't know but
it's weird huh what is this that's why
that's not for ambos boys okay oddly
enough the cat symbolism seems to be
following me throughout this game mr.
midnight oh no is this your head
probably not wait a second this is not
my kitty what a weird all righty then
but I am hearing those creaks upstairs
so I imagine that this part of the
chapter is gonna be a lot more
disturbing than the last one
oh I didn't read that oh you guys ready
welcome home beautiful kitten we hope
you like you new bird be nice neat your
food love Claire and me
okay then did you steal my cat or do you
think that I'm your cat a cooker to cook
my mommy told me how to use this but
unfortunately I don't like to light the
matches though okay so is there anything
I can grab immediately like that's first
and foremost Lu shoppi shiny dive it can
be good to have you to dry my little
hands I don't have soup I don't need a
spoon spatula yummy honey bag flour Rose
baking soda ah there we go always had
the biggest cupcakes in a pine cone so I
think that's everything that I need from
there and I don't know why on their
ingredient shelf there's a human skull
okay oh god there's so many things that
I could easily overlook if I don't just
spastically click on everything in sight
okay whatever I did my best and I did
pretty good do I need any firewood
firewood keep the chimney warm mr.
midnight those girls they took my kitty
and time for nightmares Oh white I'm at
the bottom of the well but that doesn't
make a lot of sense what the hell
happened oh hello little baby what are
you doing here what an adorable little
baby nobody loves you but you're so
pretty I like you
at least you're on the wall like a
picture so everyone can see you great
secret bottle with a secretive bottle
that is a frickin Rock I'm very curious
right now what could it be
it's a rock it's a rock oh I see you
have it comfortable there little baby
did your mommy drop you I bet she did
because she was sick it's not your fault
Oh God you seem fresh are you still
alive oh you took your placenta with you
the placenta is like a jet pack of blood
and nutrients oh my goodness gracious
gravy Oh
oh hello there's the bottle I did not
see that I'm very curious right now good
for you
we're gonna get there eventually you're
not gonna fall to your doom I can't get
there from here
I need a bridge well what do I have I've
got a pot baking soda and a knife
I don't know baking powder to make soft
dough bigger and beautiful well then
what about a knife to dig out like a
brick or something use a knife with Fran
sharp a knife to cut stuff and protect
me from kitty and kitty from evil
probably what could it be maybe I could
throw the knife at it hey I won't do but
I definitely do need the knife later so
if I stop with the pill I'm gonna go
over there I'm gonna need things to be
able to get out of here got more
ingredients like like salt a very good
ingredient I don't know what form and
maybe I can make a baking soda volcano
I might help ya looks like a seed not a
very good seed oh it's somebody else's
food pepper okay apparently I'm gonna
make a soup and I don't know why why am
I gonna make a soup all right then
water running for some reason if I had a
pot then I could fill the pot with water
I guess oh if I had pot I could put the
pot there we go
got it gadi okay water in the pot ready
to cook and there's matches to light the
oven but why am I doing this I seem to
be getting a lot of ingredients but I
don't know exactly why they don't smell
myself firestick flowers it's a lovely
painting over there I imagine that the
pill is always gonna lead me into the
well I don't think I need them you know
I'm starting to think that maybe Fran
bow doesn't know what's on the pill and
what's off the pill anymore it's kind of
danced between two cuz I don't imagine
that this is a real place in the middle
of the forest
it's got to be hello are you dude that
is not my country tea pot is no tea
delicious and beautiful cake absolutely
yummy favourite should I maybe just a
little oh I ate some well that probably
wasn't a good decision oh that really
probably wasn't a good session now I
understand what the deer wanted back in
the hospital oh that's right good
reference the deer in the hospital its
head fell off
was that it I think that's what happened
it wanted its head on the wall silly me
yes you're silly oh wait there was
something down there that I think I
coulda grabbed there's like some dust
around there yeah vase avaaz to put some
flowers in its vlogs if I would inline
to be burned hi oh this doesn't look
good
is this why okay that's why there were
two girls in the first picture there was
a girl with two heads in the first
picture oh hi oh my goodness the smell
hi poor girl who could have done this
and why I need to be careful and protect
my kitty and myself yeah Oh chance jazz
ants I get it I get it it makes sense
now okay the typewriter and it works I
guess I could write but there's no paper
and a good writer has to know what to
write about first well I could have
taken more paper from that kid whose
head exploded that would have been a
little more prudent of me there are many
books and things on the Shelf owls and
cats are a bit alike yeah except one's a
burden one with feline stares end up in
a wall maybe that was the door I made
now disappeared have to find another way
out that does make sense though many
tiny paintings and there is a cat okay
so if I go up here I'm just gonna
explore a little bit more than Oh fun
door open let me see what's inside
I've got candles to light up the
darkness I'm getting a lot of things
sisters they look like doors empty that
looks fun monster who likes goats they
need to go to like skeletons you never
know and there's something there that
could be pull Oh bah go up there in a
second I'm gonna explore the rest of the
house first
lovely mirror no reflection you're a
vampire it's very obvious it's that
monster in so much blood it looks like a
very old painting and something over
here tweezers to pick up things in my
little hands
I just noticed how disturbing the
amalgam of faces was in the top left I
was too much focused on the doll been in
the bottom left and the baby doll in the
cage uhh these toys are so ugly
all right good I hope they didn't hear
me I don't want them trying to catch me
and kill me oh that would just be the
worst I'm pretty sure I just want to
test yeah that's obvious ok so that fell
me back down in the well oh ok hang on
cozy and warm let me just double-check
that I got everything that I needed from
there
I forgot that I could double click a
super long
come on come on come on we don't have
all day hello doll who caught you I
don't know if anybody caught him her I
hope this never happens to me and Kanna
did in the asylum because it doesn't
need to happen if I'm clever enough good
point
white candles are everywhere but the
ones that I picked up hi how's it going
there oh good I see the sisters they
look alike yeah their eyes are
completely whitened
oh I just got so many chills down my
spine oh my god
there's so many things in this room that
I don't like uh the Toys in the Attic
always carry sadness with them I mean
the main point being the thing under the
sheets but also that mannequin in the
corner these down here that Chinese doll
the Scorpion is no Kay but the Fox on
the wall a lot of tiny stuff maybe I
need to use it tweezers that's some
lovely Greek oh my god everything in
this room gives me the heebie-jeebies
this is like a room of my nightmares
often one okay
okay oh hello little babies who sued you
two together I don't want to know it
looks like it hurts don't cry alright
yeah don't do that you just smile and be
nice it's time to sleep oh oh ah
foxy oh no I wish I could take you out
of here alrighty then let's see the
sisters but they look old in this
picture just one mr. midnight are you
here kitty meow yeah mr. midnight don't
be scared I'm here for you Fran is that
really you oh dear finally it's me come
closer please let me see you oh it is Oh
Fran I'm so happy to see you I missed
you very much I had dreams about you and
here you are thank you for not giving up
I love you my friend I love you too mr.
midnight and I really missed you
oh dear Fran how did you find this place
after those people took you away in the
woods I tried to follow them but after a
while I got lost my senses were too weak
to track you I tried to catch some food
to recover but something happened
somebody took me and put me in this cage
I wish nothing of this had happened to
us kitty I will open this cage Fran I'm
very tired I wish everything was just a
bad dream everything is gonna be fine
we just have to get out of here Fran can
I ask you something sure mr. midnight
anything you need
did you feel my presence in your dream
yes I did you told me to take the
medicine and find you
what medicine Fran it wasn't really me
talking to you I think somebody was
helping us get together was that the
mechanical Kenny or is this something
bad in Sinister every time I had dreams
about you I felt the presence of
something else really what kind of
presence for what I felt it wasn't human
but it was really peaceful and kind well
whatever it is it's good and it brought
us together Fran did you hear that did
you I don't know what did you hear oh
I'll see what it is I'll try to find the
key to unlock you alright I love you
smooches okay then can I get that
umbrella no no umbrella okay fine I
don't know what the noises are mr. rat
it's time to get up and another rat a
while ago he tired sir
all righty then hi Jesus goddamn it I
feel like I could have clicked on that
but I wasn't ready uh-huh
I'm not ready for the ghost to disappear
out of nowhere in front of me hello hi
oh you scared me I thought nobody was
living here there you are
we were waiting for you where is your
head my head my head is just in the
right place you the prices being from
the other world
would you ever believe us I'm confused
what are you talking about Fran bow
that's your name right and your mom and
dad died tragically very beautiful
brutal not beautiful right
and now you really want to know who
killed them right you're scaring me how
can you know all this we just know we
have to we are part of the world they're
zombies and bad things happen to all of
us all the time I wish I was at home
with mommy and daddy right now
don't wish for things that can't be done
find solutions and answers yes but the
pain I feel is so great I can't see
solutions drink some tea you need some
cake it will make you feel better thank
you
but really I need to know who told you
these things about me are you scared
moving Fran of course not I'm just
curious that's all I'm mostly confused
you haven't asked about your cat yet mr.
midnight it's very odd for a girl who
loves a cat more than anything else in
the world
and Jed you look so calm after finding
him in a cage hungry and scared
shouldn't it be ours trembling in fear
of you I love them and that is why I'm
here I didn't mean to be rude you want
him back yes please I really wish to
have him back he's my best friend we've
always had him freeze Hellas how it is
this you came here it's a long story I
escaped from place a very ugly place
they opened the heads of children to
find out what's wrong with them
Phil told me a secret and I was clever
enough to find the way out and then I
came into the woods and met a giant and
I killed the bug it was terrible and
then I met a rat who wanted to get his
hair done and then I made a door and
that door took me here but when I
entered the door something happened I
don't remember anything else oh and I
saw a real pinecone family that was
before I came here
they live in mr. Antonio's house they
like berries and and I and I saw flying
insects that got stuck in trees because
they have long hair that was also in the
woods and now here I am looking for mr.
midnight now that she says it all out
loud that sounds really really crazy or
like the ramblings of the imagination of
a ten-year-old cuz maybe that's what
this is all about maybe the imagination
imagination of a ten-year-old is fueling
these nightmares now is some adventure
how old are you friend I'm 10 years old
but I have to turn 11 soon and you we
are 16 years old much older than us so
you have to obey you can't tell me what
to do I just wish you would open the
cage so I can go home with my kitty you
haven't even asked our name was that's
not polite as you shouldn't wander
around in a house without
are you stupid a stupid little girl with
no family at all
I'm not stupid and I do have a family I
have Aunt Grace in my kitten are you
crying because if you are you'll get in
trouble if you don't do exactly as we
say you and your cat will die screw you
you understand no you don't scare me
free my cat now do it as you asked for
it oh if you don't do what we ask for
bad things will happen to your cat we
will force you to kill him with your own
hands you are evil and poisoned I'll do
whatever you say oh okay so I didn't
have a choice anyway I can take him I
can fight him it's still one-on-one even
if you have two hands I need you to
perform a little magic trick on us do
you like magic
yes and he also did magic but she didn't
have any idea how it actually do it
anyway there's enough for your ramblings
this magic is very powerful tremendous
and dangerous here is the recipe be
cautious and precise otherwise terrible
things can happen okay Oh summon the old
lost boy this seems like one of the
games you play at midnight and the demon
comes out and consumes your entire
family I don't know if I'm going to be
able to do it do yourself we can't do it
it would kill us you see we weren't like
we used to be two different people in
two different ballgames but how is that
you're like this now one night at
midnight a long time ago something
appeared in front of us we thought it
was an angel but it was not he decided
that we should spend its energy to Yemen
he cast us to be like this we never
understood why we have a spells bring
him back but we will do that later when
we are not attached to each other any
and show him that he is powerless and he
will regret it that sounds terrible I'll
try my best though la-de-da-de-da we are
going to gather some things you will
need for the ritual and because you have
been a very naughty girl you won't even
be able to talk to you Cass it'll have
to wait until we come back oh please let
me talk to him let me give him some food
no you can't oh that's mean and Fran do
you see this key can you imagine what
can be open with it can you you silly
silly girl anyway goodbye
twinsies I don't even know what your
name was I forgot to ask or I forgot to
pay attention when you said it boy they
sure were mean I wonder if there was
another way to go through that dialogue
that I would be able to actually see my
cat I mean I was a little bit
competitive attitude but hey they
deserved it okay lost in the darkness
lost in tears your body becomes a life
or the hands of the one angel that
brings you sorrow you will need the
heart of a frog the head of a young
virgin hair and blood from a black cat
Oh God a pentagram made of ashes the
burnt body of a fox this must all be
cooked together in a pot or cauldron
with plenty of water when you were eight
about to drink the potion repeat these
words man Ambu cog is any oh man I erred
Vontae ear abura
Asha Burman
janay belukha Emmer if aware through
word apparently I either does summoned a
demon or every Sims from Sims is coming
to find me and kill me anyway so that's
just something I'll have to face when it
gets to so I imagine that because of
these ingredients in the way that
they're laid out there must be a way
around it that I wouldn't need to do
exactly what they're saying so maybe I
can make them think because I did gather
a lot of ingredients which would mean
that I would have a lot of options to do
things so it's entirely possible that
there's another way around this because
I like one of the ingredients it's very
obviously blood and hair from a cat oh
whoops didn't mean to actually do that
but blood and hair from a cat which
means that I would have to hurt my cat
there's no goddamn way I'm doing that no
way in hell okay hello hi are you the
one I'm trying to say okay goodbye it's
him again but I haven't taken my pills
well I imagine that a lot of this is
really weird when you haven't taken her
pills but you haven't thought about that
he opened the window thank you who is he
maybe he's the mysterious force that's
bringing me and my cat together oh hey
how's it going there buddy hey you how'd
you guess who's speaking me I'm turd I
have to take you
that's what is it yeah I mean great
danger don't try to go why do you say
that maybe because they're creepy and
mysterious and want to kill me in my cat
good girl I'm a toad and I know I can
swim away from a place but they won't
let me every time I try to get out here
I magically come back this house is
liars huge magnet and I don't know how
they work a toad egg hat magnet they
love us but not to give us her candy
users Oh got em I won't trust them I
promise they gave you ready for love
and right how did you know that there's
either decorate one roof well I can be
here if you got tea tried Busch easily
wrong what should i do then
I'm not a lever though but if I were you
I'll be creative
mmm creative I'll try my best
okay I'll do my best angle will you live
it all out yeah yeah but I'm gonna do
okay now I wonder a rusty old bicycle in
the middle of an aisle a big big rock
I'll leave it right there
so is there anything else that I need
moonlight on the water you're so
beautiful
and okay so I don't know if there I'm
just gonna see ah I knew this place
might be different hello
finally my sister is trying to catch me
but I ran away I'm scared
would you help me I have a monster
inside my head okay fine then
I always feel like the moon is following
me I wonder if the moonlight does the
same job as sunlight something like that
I don't think it would take me very far
there's nothing but water around this
house rusty voiceover doubters I guess
some people believe you when it's
written down doubters need the truth on
paper okay so that means that I if I
edit the paper bada-bing bada-boom I
might be able to trick them into doing
something close I am a clever girl just
like Jurassic Park
I'm the cleverest girl and also it's
really amazing that I'm hauling around a
giant pot full of water while I'm
walking around I don't know where I'm
storing it but man this girl is strong
okay so if I use this I could write
something look what well maybe some new
ingredients for something else like a
new way to go about things maybe that
would be a good idea I don't know let me
examine this again cauldre the plain
water or the Frog hunter a young version
that's all bad that's all bad stuff all
bad stuff
okay so there's got to be a way to edit
this see Oh what should I do
I refuse to do this it can't be a good
thing maybe there's something else I can
do I know there's got to be something
else like a new so write it all down
there we go close the window so the cold
wind stays out now I can light the oven
I don't like to do it fire I can use
that okay so that's gonna be boiling so
then I could okay there's something that
I could cut Oh
combine the moonlight seed ah okay
moonlight okay so it's moonlight seed
and in the backyard there was some
moonlight so she wondered if moonlight
does the same thing as sunlight so that
must moan there must be a way nothing
there's no there must be a way that this
works
haha there there we go okay now we're
making progress
okay so now I got a really nice blue
rose and that supplements or what
exactly but either way we're on the
right step so we're on the right path
but this is just one step in the path
okay did you find a solution already I
mentally stuck I don't know what to do
I'm mentally stuck I know you have
something that makes sense you see
things that I can't do you know that I'm
talking to is that you move idly but you
can talk to me blemishes measured in
horrible yes you're right I can talk to
toads I must be special have you see
every little Missy oh I'll see what I
can find
okay goodbye thank you alright I am
thoroughly stumped so I'm gonna figure
this out in the next like in between
this in the next episode and then I'll
get back to you as soon as I find out
exactly what I'm supposed to do but
thank you everybody so much for watching
I really hope you're enjoying this
series and I will get back to this real
soon as soon as i rack my brain to tell
myself oh so thank you again and as
always
how's it going there
whoa that's my head